hey what's up guys my name is jonah
welcome back to my c plus plus
series we're back at it again with those
bitwise operators so last time we had a
bit of an introduction to binary in
general and we took a look at the bit
shift left and the bit shift right
operators
if you haven't seen that video i highly
recommend you watch it because we're
basically continuing on from that video
here today now i'm not going to spend
any time today recapping what we did
last time we'll talk about
binary and bits in general so we can
jump right into the rest of the bitwise
operators that we need to talk about
which are the bitwise and the bitwise or
the bitwise
exclusive or or xor
zor and finally the bitwise not operator
the
squiggly line kind of inversion thing
bitwise invert
that's what i call it so the plan for
today is basically to take a look at
those operators and just like break down
exactly what it is they do
and then in the next video the final
video of this little series we're
actually going to
take a look at some real world examples
in which all of these operators get used
so that you can
kind of put together why they might be
used in the first place because i
understand that that's probably
one of the biggest questions people have
who are introduced to these operators
and i'm like but
why why do they even exist why do i need
them so before we jump in and start
drawing stuff on this little amazing
tablet that i have here
this video is sponsored by skillshare
now for those of you who don't know
skillshare is an amazing online learning
community
where millions of creative curious
people from all around the world come
together to learn
any number of amazing new skills that
are taught extremely professionally in
bite-sized videos
on just a whole wide variety of topics
the great thing about skillshare that i
think separates it from other kind of
similar platforms
are that the videos are so kind of
concise that then they don't just go on
for hours i mean other websites that
have courses might have
a course that goes for like 60 hours and
that's all fine but sometimes you just
don't have the time and you don't want
something that goes into that level of
depth
you just want like a nice solid concise
overview that will
kind of explain as much as possible
about that topic but be
kind of easier to consume in in kind of
shorter videos that you might have time
to catch here and there after your
busy life at work and that i think is
where skillshare
really shines and that's why i've been
appreciating it lately
so much whether you want to learn about
creative topics such as photography
videography illustration
art that kind of stuff or the more
business side of things or maybe
productivity
skillshare literally has courses on
pretty much anything you can think of
coming in at just under 10 a month for
an annual subscription skillshare is an
amazingly affordable way
to add some more learning into your life
and learn some new skills
skillshare offering the first 1000
people who click the link in description
below a free trial of skillshare premium
so go ahead and do that check it out for
free see what amazing courses are
available out there
and learn some new skills huge thank you
to skillshare as always for sponsoring
this video and now let's take a look at
the rest of the bitwise operators
okay so what you're looking at over here
are all of the bitwise operators
these two we have already covered in the
previous episodes we don't need to talk
about them today
and today is going to be about the rest
of these so we have the bitwise and
the bitwise or the bitwise xor or
exclusive or
and then the bitwise not operator now
three of these these three
they act on two different variables or
two different
bit patterns really so in other words
it's always like a
and b or a or b or
a x or b you need two values to actually
be able to use these operators
however the not operator is a unary
operator meaning that it actually acts
on a single variable so in other words
you wouldn't do
a not b that doesn't make any sense
instead you would use it with a single
value
like that all right so without further
ado let's get started and start by
talking about this
and operator over here now the and
operator is actually very similar to
our logical and logical and is basically
when we when we use a double ampersand
like this
and a bit wise and we use a single
ampersand a lot of people are confused
about the difference
because in a lot of cases this seems to
almost work the same way as the logical
and
however they are very different things
this is of course a logical and meant to
compare two kind of boolean values
whereas this is an actual bitwise
operator so what does it do and why am i
saying that it's similar to a logical
and
it compares two bits such as zero and
one
and it will return a one if both of
those bits are one otherwise it will
return a zero
so if you kind of flip this into a
logical statement if we have something
like
false and true
then we would expect to get false in
this case and in fact i don't know why i
wrote a one there it's clearly zero but
my point is that if you treat the zeros
as false
and the ones is true which is
effectively what they are then this
works in exactly the same way
as this kind of logical and both sides
of this equation have to be true
in order for this to be true because
you're effectively saying is this true
and is this true and if so then of
course the result is true one thing i
didn't point out by the way is in
comparison to these bit shift
left and right operators which obviously
take some kind of variable on the left
side and then you shift that by
like x amount of places either left or
right this
actually acts on two bit patterns so
this is simply a number in the shift
operator to actually shift by whereas
these these are specifically meant for
being used with two
variables and the bits of those
variables are the things in question
here
okay so let's get let's get back to our
little example here let's kind of expand
on this so that maybe it makes more
sense
if you're still not sure about how it
works so i'll write a little table here
so
0 and 0 will give us 0 because neither
of them are true
0 and 1 will give us 0 because well they
both have to be true
or they both have to be one in order for
us to get a one
one and zero will also give us a zero
because again they're not both
one and finally one and one of course
will give us one
because they're both one now of course
in this case we were just comparing
one bit with another single bit if we
expand this out into some kind of number
like this and we compare it like that
i'm not sure what i'm writing here then
we simply have to do this to each bit of
course so this will give us 0
one zero one because only in these two
cases are they both one
in the in this case they're both zero we
don't care about that that is still
zero and then in this case one of them
is one but they both have to be one
for us to actually get a one so this is
the result that we are left with now
what can we actually do with this
information in practice well this
bitwise and is actually very commonly
referred to
as a bit mask in fact you can use it to
mask out
selective bits what on earth do i mean
by that well if we have some
random number and i'll express it in
binary here let's just say 1 0
1 1 0 0 1 0 1 whatever
if i am interested in checking the state
of
a single bit here i can actually do that
using the bitwise and operator
so for example if i'm interested in
knowing the state of
this bit over here so that's 0 1 2 3 4
5 the fifth bit will say from this right
side over here
all i need to do is construct another
value here another number that will act
as a mask that i can use to select
this bit and then see what its value is
so how do we build this mask well what
do we know about
this and operator we know that only in
the case
of both of these values being one do we
get a one in every other case we get
zero
so what we can do is actually fill this
second number here the number that we'll
be adding that first
variable we care about with we can fill
it with zeros except for the spot where
the bit we're interested in
lies so in other words over here i'll
put a one
everywhere else we just simply put a
zero
and when i add these two values together
well you can already see what this is
going to end up with
there's zeros everywhere so we know that
all of the places that have zeros
no matter what the other number is we'll
also get zero it doesn't matter what the
other bits are
we'll always get zero if this side is
zero however in
this kind of place with this bit that we
are interested in
we're going to get a one in this case
because it's set to one
and one and one is one or if it had been
zero well what would we get zero so now
we can
very easily check the state of that
particular bit
because even though it happens to be all
the way over here this variable here our
resulting variable is really only going
to be one of two states either
completely zero
because well it returns zero and the
whole number is zero
or something else so or greater than
zero
right in this case we have zero one two
three
four five to the power of five is 32 so
this value would actually give us 32
so i'll just kind of write that in here
but of course if it had been zero then
it would have given us zero
and so what we can do with this value is
we can for example
pass the result this little bit wise
result
into an if statement like so and
obviously if it's not
zero so 32 for example is going to be
true and we can act accordingly
however if it is zero then it's going to
be false and we don't go into that
branch
and that's actually a very common use
case of this bitwise and operator
because the value doesn't have to be
one for this to be true any value other
than 0
in a boolean sense is going to be true
even a negative value
if there's any data present aside from 0
then it's true and of course this
masking situation works for
other use cases not just checking the
state of a single bit
so for example what i could use it for
is to literally select a whole group of
bits or clear a group of bits
so for example if i take that same
number that i had over here and i pop it
here
if i want to just isolate this group
over here or maybe i want to clear this
to zero
then all i have to do is and this with
zero zero zero zero zero
and then one one one one and that will
of course
give me zero zero zero zero
zero and then for this side over here it
will give me
0 1 0 1 which coincidentally is exactly
the value we started with so what i've
done is i've effectively removed this
whole
bunch of bits they're irrelevant i'm
just focusing on my little selection
here so this bitwise and operator
we can use to mask out or select
specific
bits okay so what about the or operator
well the or operator works
much the same way and again this is
similar to a logical or i'll try to make
these longer so you can tell
they're not ones if either of them are
true then the result is true so if
either of these are one we'll get a one
well they're both zero so we'll get zero
otherwise for this we'll get one
right because are either of them one yes
then same of course
for this and also for one or one so it's
kind of like
the opposite in a way i mean this is
obviously still going to be zero in both
cases and this is going to be one in
both cases
but it works very similarly to a logical
or operator
right if either of these values are true
then we get
true and just to give you a bit of an
example if i had some
random value like this then you can see
that
the result would be something like that
in fact the result would be that i don't
know why it's
something like that one thing you can do
with these exercises by the way is if
you really are kind of new to these
operators then feel free to actually try
and do these
on paper by yourself before i kind of
give you
the answers it'll force you to like
think a little bit and actually remember
and learn how these operators work a lot
better and a lot quicker okay so what
does this let me do in comparison to
this whole bit masking thing
well the or works kind of in the
opposite way we can use this
and like in this case to take away bits
right so just to get rid of bits
entirely with or
we can actually use it to add bits so
if we had this whole group of zeros here
right that we
we just took them all away and i
actually wanted to add these
bits back i could order those zeros with
this kind of bit pattern one zero one
one zero
and i would get them back now in this
particular example i would also actually
need to shift them left though
because you can see that in this case
this this value doesn't start at the
first kind of position this is our first
position this is our least significant
bit
but we need to start kind of writing
these values in here so let's actually
do that this will be a good example i
think
so this is the original value that i had
over here i'll stop drawing stuff on top
of everything so that it's more clear
and we added it by this so now we're
left with this
so with this specific value that we had
i'll write it out over here
how do i get back to the original value
if i know that what i took away were
these bits over here
well again if i try to order them by one
zero one one zero
well that wouldn't really be that useful
to me because obviously what that would
do in this case is well these are all
zeros they remain
zeros but then here what would happen is
i would change some of them to ones
and it would just become this which is
still not my original number so what i
have to do is actually take this number
over here
this bit pattern which i want to end up
in this place
and first shift it left by in this case
four places right
one two three four would shift it from
here
to and this is kind of the usefulness of
using
photoshop here not drawing on paper i
can literally move it
over here right four places that's how
much i've moved it by and so what i end
up with
is just zeros over here and now if i
order these two values together
one zero one zero zero one one
zero one then guess what i'm left with
my
original value so in summary what would
this look like if it was
actual code and not just a drawing on a
screen we would write some code such as
this so int a
i'll say is equal to this which we know
is 0
1 0 1. now i'll pretend that we're
writing in binary here if you ever want
to write in
in binary directly in your sql source
code you can actually do 0
b and then the pattern that you want
right so it's kind of similar to
hexadecimal how you could just put a
little 0x and then write them in
hexadecimal you can do the same
in i think it's c plus plus like i don't
know what version onwards but you can
now
you should be able to do zero b and then
whatever value you want so if we have
this a variable and we want it to turn
into this we'll create our little
b variable here which will be this value
that we want to add back
so one zero one one zero and by the way
this leading zero is of course
kind of useless we can get rid of it if
we want to and then i'm simply going to
take b
and shift it left by four places so i'll
write some code like that
and then finally our result right which
i'll call
c will be a or b and then this c
variable is what this will be this is a
new
c variable and here is an actual c
plus source code example if you want
something that you can actually run
yourself
the only kind of different thing i'm
doing here is actually putting this
final integer into a bit set of nine
bits
just so that i can actually see it
printed in binary when i run my program
and the result of running this is this
which of course
is my original value so that is the
bitwise and and the bitwise or now these
two operators are used pretty often to
be honest in terms of like bitwise
operators and their users
these are used pretty frequently now
bitwise xor and not
they're not used as often not is
actually very
useful with and because whilst the or
operator can actually
set zeros to be one we can't ever
set a one to be zero using the or
operator because if we order with zero
we'll just get one
however and obviously if we want to set
something to zero
we can just end that bit with zero and
we'll get
zero so what we can actually do is
combine the not operator with the and
operator to be able to toggle bits on
and off so here's an
example of that in this example that we
had earlier
i was able to set this bit to one leave
everything else as zero
in order to actually see the value of
this specific bit
but what if i want to set that to zero
well if i know what bit i actually have
it's number zero one two three
four five we as humans can easily just
build up a mask for that so i could
write one one
one zero that's the one i want to set to
zero
and then one one one one one right but
how do we do that programmatically
well what we can do is still actually
have this specific bit
set to one so if we had like an enum
with like some bit flags or
whatever then we would assume we would
already have like a defined for that
specific bit
but if i take this value zero zero zero
one zero
zero zero zero zero and i bit y is not
it right then the value that i get is
one
one one zero one one one one one and now
what i can do is take this
and and it with this original variable
here
and then every single bit will remain
untouched
except for this one which will get set
to zero right so in other words if we
take this original variable
this will change to zero everything else
will stay at one
and i'm able to do that by just simply
knowing which bit
it is that i want to toggle off and then
inverting it right by using the bitwise
not operator to just create this new
variable which has ones everywhere
except for this place
so that's kind of my real world example
of not
that's where i've used it most often and
then exor
in my experience has mostly been used
for like hashing
and we'll talk more about that in the
next episode but basically this
exclusive or
is only going to return true if the bits
you are comparing
are different right so if you think
about all the other operators we've got
they work for whether or not the bits
are the same
right so in other words zero zero gives
us zero zero zero gives us a zero in
both and and or
and then zero and one gives us zero zero
or one gives us one so we have a
different kind of
operator for whether or not we want to
return
a zero or a one if the bits are
different
and will always return zero if they're
different or will always return one if
they're different
but we don't have something that will
specifically give us a one
if they are different because obviously
and will give us a one if they're the
same
or will give us a one if they're the
same i want something that gives me
zero if they're the same and 1 if
they're different and that's what xor
does
so 0 x or 0 gives us
0 because they're not exclusive they're
the same 0
x or 1 gives me 1 because they're
different 1 x or
0 gives me one because they're different
one x or one gives me
zero so you can see that we have
something that is quite
different from the other operators
specifically it works kind of like
an or except in this case if they're the
same
it gives me a zero so it's useful to
kind of flip bits
now what's kind of interesting and a
little bit unique about this xor
operator
is if you have a value such as this and
you xor it with
itself so if i had like int a equals
well let's just say this and then i did
int
b equals a xor a
right so i'm xoring it with itself this
will always give me zero
the reason is that obviously if we take
one one zero
one and we export with one one zero one
none of the bits are exclusive they're
all the same because it's the same exact
value
so it will always return zero so
if you want a really cool way to set a
variable to zero
you can just xor it with itself and the
funny thing is sometimes
this is actually faster than setting a
variable to zero on some architectures
but like not really so don't go ahead
and actually do this
please don't maybe it will be fast and
so that is our overview of the rest of
these bitwise operators
okay so i hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please don't forget to
hit the like button
in the description below i'm this
youtube thing is hard
now that we've covered all of the
bitwise operators the next real step is
learning how to use them in practice
next time in the final episode of this
kind of
like bitwise binary mini series we're
going to take a look at some real
examples however if you've been using
all of this kind of bitwise stuff lately
and you have some examples of your own
to give then please leave them in the
comment section below
i think that would be great for people
who want to kind of move on from this
video but maybe don't know where to go
and don't necessarily want to wait for
the next one but anyway thank you guys
for watching don't forget to click the
link in the description to get your free
trial
of skillshare premium and i will see you
next time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
you